i started in 2017
or 2016 just with a blog and i was just
writing down these weird food
experiments i was doing for my
autoimmune disorder
and so i started with the blog i got a
couple of podcast invitations from the
blog just to talk about diet things
really took off when joe rogan invited
me on to talk about the carnivore diet
but then i was kind of niched into being
a diet person and
i had zero interest in being a diet
person
i was always like
if there's anything well below zero
interest right i always kind of scoffed
at people who are gluten free and like
you just didn't take anybody who had
some sort of ideology surrounding diet
seriously
i was like yeah vegans you know
gluten-free people
i'm not one of them right and then this
autoimmune disorder
being
you know put into remission with this
ridiculous diet i was like okay well
that's great for me i kind of feel like
i have to talk about that but i didn't
want to be niched in i certainly didn't
want to be a diet person forever and i
i think by the time i rolled around to
having my own podcast i'd been on a lot
of other people's podcasts and somebody
reached out and said oh i'll produce
your podcast like you'd be a good
podcast host i'll produce your podcast
just give it a shot and so i started
so i started just kind of out of
curiosity
and then
i thought i could use it to also
research some of my health issues to
talk to
you know have the ability to talk to
experts
which is an unbelievable
you know blessing just to be able to
reach out to people and talk to them so
i started it that way but then
i wasn't i'm not super interested in
you know i've kind of figured out my
health so i'm not really interested in
talking about health i was like okay
i'll delve into some other things and i
started i've got this series and this is
what i find really interesting it's
opposing views
i'll have yeah i i'm i really really
really like opposing views so one person
on
they're usually generally
uh on a contentious issue you know like
an abortion you'd have someone who's
very very pro-choice and someone who's
very very pro-life
and then i'll have a conversation with
both of them and try and ask them
similar questions and try and stay in
the middle ground and part of the reason
i wanted to do that was
because
i grew up kind of i went to an art
school i went to a couple of art schools
so i grew up in a really
more
liberal like very very liberal community
and then
my dad is more conservative and i was
like there's this huge bridge between
some of my friends and some of my
conservative liberal friends and some of
my conservative friends and
you know the other side it you can't
just say oh well the other side's crazy
right it's like
each side is crazy then
yeah everybody's crazy yeah exactly
exactly
so
i don't know if that answer is that's
kind of a roundabout way of answering
your question but i think i just started
started it because partly it was coveted
was isolating it's like i'm pretty
extroverted i wanted to talk to people
and then just see where it goes but the
podcast takes maybe 10 of my time like i
record a couple of times a week and then
most of the production the production's
outsourced um
i have a social media person so what
takes up most of my time are
you know products and brand management
and pr and like legal
for my dad's brand so much bigger
it doesn't look like that on the outside
but oh no i mean i think your dad's
brand appear i mean it comes i mean
there's there's books there's tours
there's
interviews there's
i mean he's selling i mean doing your
personality tests he has an online um
lecture series that you can buy which i
did
um things like that so no it does seem
like a big business and um
but so now i'm sure that there's there's
lots i i agree i mean i do the podcast
and one comes out every week and i love
doing it but it's not necessarily a
super dominant thing in time i do i do a
lot of the research part of it like i
love learning about people before
um
i'm curious about having these opposing
views um because i've seen that with
your podcast and um i think it's a
fascinating topic um to and a way to
present
an idea
to people so what do you end up finding
in the end with most of these
interviews
that you sort of mediate between the two
because i'm guessing like they probably
go at it a little bit you pose questions
okay so they're actually i thought
having a debate actually i was just
stressed out about the idea of having a
debate and so how it's structured is
i'll talk to one person first
and then i'll separately talk to the
other person
so they don't get to communicate with
each other which makes
yeah and so i've got some criticisms
like oh it'd be better as a debate but
some of these arguments are so different
that i don't even think we could have a
useful conversation like i don't think i
could mediate between these
so
huh i mean yeah i feel like part of my
podcast and and what it's like in the
intro is that no matter who i talk to
you end up realizing that people are
more alike than they are different and i
think that you know that's i like to
highlight that show that and get into a
deep enough conversation where we get to
the point where it's like you know we
all kind of want the same thing i guess
i use you know you could use covered
vaccines as an example like you get it
because you want to be healthy and you
don't get it because you want to be
healthy like we're more alike than we
are different and so i think it'd be
fascinating to have them like go
head-to-head because
you know it humanizes people and you
know just like you know in your
experience if you go head-to-head with
somebody like you both get humanized and
you know when you're face to face with
somebody even just like this
um
you know you underst you know there's
more compassion
we'll see i'm gonna i'm really really
tempted to test it out i think it would
be entertaining but some of these like
some of these people
really hate each other right like even
the so pro-choice in pro-life
for example
it's interesting because they're both
arguing
to keep they're arguing on behalf of
someone right they're both arguing on
behalf of somebody else
kind of but you too but it's their view
too
or they wouldn't be saying it
yeah this is true but i mean
i mean most of the arguments i think
i've seen are from a place of compassion
okay i did an immigration one right and
and the one the one guy who's
pro-immigration was like yeah it's great
for the economy you bring talented
people in everybody spends more money
right and it benefits society as a whole
and the person which that's a very
simplified you know description of what
he said but then the other guy
was like oh no if you bring immigrants
in then people who make less money you
know you're talking about seriously
low-income people then those people have
a harder time
finding jobs it's not the rich people or
the people with jobs that you really
have to worry about it's these people in
low-income neighborhoods that are
actually at risk
and so
usually i think after the opposing views
i come away thinking yeah they're both
kind of right like they're both kind of
right but they're not arguing about
exactly they're talking about two
different parts of the same argument
it's it's fascinating anyway i really
enjoy it
what do you because i know that
one of the things that you have
confessed is that you're kind of a
contrarian you love to you know you're
disagreeable um what is it about it that
fascinates you when people don't agree
or when you have opposing views
i think it's because usually going into
those i'm you know more on one side of
it and i would say generally speaking
and probably side more with the
conservative initially like the idea i
have whatever the problem is
i've noticed i probably have more of a
conservative idea
and then going into it i can
i'm not particularly i don't think i'm
particularly attached
to ideas i don't mind being wrong right
it doesn't you know i think i've been
wrong so many times that i don't care
anymore right it's probably part of
being open when you're open you're okay
with being wrong because that's it's
like part of the inherent nature of
being open yeah yeah exactly and it
doesn't matter right as long as you're
trying to figure out what's true
does it matter so are you
you're almost like the beta test for the
opposing views
to be more on one side generally but
then in the end you end up realizing
that the other side isn't wrong either
like i think you're your own beta test
for how well it would go
if opposing views came together because
then naturally there's probably a little
bit of contentiousness some sparks and
then essentially like it gets humanized
yeah this is true but then when you look
at youtube comments that's not what you
get you just get you know and i usually
tell people like just
try and be reasonable in the comments
because i'm trying to get people onto
the show so if
you know one side is just constantly
being more attacked then people are less
likely to say yes coming on because why
would anyone want to come onto a show
where they're just gonna get attacked
right so like just keep it down
but uh people are people can be pretty
one-sided right and just not understand
the other side at all
so your hope would be that you'd listen
to it and go okay you know these are
both people and maybe
they both have points even though i
don't agree with all of them but i don't
know how
well the average person does that
otherwise i don't think we'd be in the
situation we're in with covid and with
politics that we are right now like
there's obviously some sort of gap
between people's ability to understand
the other side
what's the what's the disconnect i'm i'm
but naturally an open-minded person i
love to i don't mind being wrong either
if someone says something and i can
change my mind that's fine i actually
look at his progress like i can learn
and get smarter yeah
um what what's the what's the what's the
what's the issue with people
being so hard-headed and have such
cognitive dissonance around issues like
where does that where does that come
from and is it something that actually
needs to be solved or
not hmm
did you ever do one of dad's personality
tests i actually did
okay and is your openness like off the
charts yeah
yeah okay i'd have to look at the
percentage of what it was but
i don't know i i remember it being very
high
yeah so i i think
i think for more open people then they
can go either way and i think the
percentage of you know if you scored
like 85th or above or something like
ridiculously high people who are at the
50th percentile are so much lower than
that i think it's difficult to
understand like um i know the type of
person i have a difficult time
understanding and it's someone who
doesn't really want to do things like
they'd rather stay home they're not as
interested in meeting new people right
they're not particularly interested in
ideas and i think the
if you just look at the personality
scale the average person
just isn't
that interested in changing their mind
right so so i don't and i don't even
think that's something you can learn so
i'm not even entirely sure how to fix
that problem right if it's not if it's
just kind of a human nature
as an average i don't know
but i was trying to with opposing views
but i'm not sure if it's working to be
honest it's entertaining either way i
think it's a great format and i love the
idea of them going head to head because
i think that like foundationally we're
more alike than we are different so i
think it would be really entertaining to
hear people go at it and then of course
like i think in the end everybody ends
up getting the same place you do where
you're like hmm they're not wrong either
and then you go like the truth is always
in the middle i mean even if you look at
politically like people usually want the
most democratic republican and most
republican democrat like people don't
actually generally really want the ends
of the spectrum they want somewhere in
the middle but yet we call it one thing
or another and when we name things it
can't be anything else
yeah i completely agree i don't know i'm
gonna like i said i'm going to try this
in person but
some of these people have spent their
entire lives arguing one point of view
right and they know each other right if
if all you do is focus on the
immigration one for example if all you
do is focus on how immigration is bad
you know everybody who's telling people
that immigration is good you know all of
them and you don't like them already
right
and so and even the when i had the
abortion opposing views like they knew
who each other were and they didn't like
it like so there's already they've spent
so much time focused on one way of
thinking
that putting that person in in the room
and trying to have a discussion with
someone who thinks the opposite way
would be interesting i don't know if it
would i don't know what would happen